SPEAKER: Determining the right
price for your retail products
is a difficult task.
Price items too high, and
you might lose business.
Price them too low, and you
lower your profit margin.
So how do you incorporate
different data sources
to analyze historical
pricing trends
and make predictions
on future demand?
Today we'll show you how
using Google's data cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
There are lots of
different data sources
that can help you understand
how to optimally price items.
You might have information
on transactions,
details on products, like
categories and list prices,
and data on the
customers themselves.
However, the data required
to drive pricing insight
is often disparate, potentially
coming from different systems
with their own formats.
One way to make working with
these sources more effective
is to combine key attributes
into a single cleaned
and standardized schema, which
we'll refer to as the Common
Data Model, or CDM.
In this tutorial, we'll
use Dataprep by Trifecta
to standardize data coming
from different sources
and unify the necessary
fields in the CDM table, which
will live in BigQuery, our
fully managed, scalable data
warehouse.
Once data is formatted
for analysis,
we'll show how analysts can
explore historical trends
to understand the impact
of prior pricing changes.
Additionally, we'll use
BigQuery's machine learning
capabilities to create
predictive models that
estimate future sales.
Finally, we'll use the
output of these models
within a Looker dashboard to
create what-if scenarios, where
business users can
analyze what sales
might look like with
certain price changes.
So let's jump in.
Inside of Dataprep,
you create flows, which
represent a data pipeline.
Within this flow,
we have connected
each of our data sets.
In this case, we're using
Google Sheets and a table
containing our customer
descriptions in BigQuery.
But you can connect a variety
of different data sources,
including flat files,
transactional databases,
and SaaS tools, like Salesforce.
You might notice that
we have one transaction
file for each month,
representing the orders that
were placed in that period.
The first thing you'll want
to do is combine those files.
In Dataprep, you use recipes
to transform and join data
together.
Opening this recipe, you can
see that there are actually
two things happening.
First, we're unioning or
combining the transactions data
into one single set.
But then we're standardizing
customer descriptions.
This is because the
names of customers
are sometimes misspelled
or represented differently
across transactions.
But with Dataprep, you can
use a fuzzy matching algorithm
to standardize customer
names with similar strings
where values with characters in
common are clustered together
or pronunciation where
values that sound alike
are clustered together.
This way, we make sure customers
are represented consistently.
Outside of the
transactions recipe,
we have other recipes to
calculate accurate pricing
using functions that
pivot, aggregate,
and join to customer data, and
a recipe that automatically
reformats the prepared
data structure
to match the existing
CDM table schema,
using Dataprep's rapid
target functionality.
Finally, the CDM is
pushed into BigQuery.
And not only can we
manually run this flow,
but we can also set it to
run on a scheduled basis,
so the CDM table
is always fresh.
With our prepared
data in BigQuery,
we're ready to take
a look at what's
happened historically when we've
changed the price of an item.
Here, we're using standard SQL
to create a temporary table
with one row for
each price change,
and it contains
relevant information,
like the total number of
orders at the current price
point compared to orders at
the previous price point.
With this temp table in place,
we can do things like look
at the average
price change or see
how sales have changed relative
to the price difference.
Now that we have historical
analysis squared away,
let's incorporate machine
learning to predict
what will happen in the future.
With BigQueryML, we can
build an ARIMA model,
one of the most
widely used approaches
for statistical forecasting
with time series.
And this will use
historical sales
for each product to predict
the future demand, all
in just a few lines of SQL.
How cool is that?
So using BigQuery, we're
able to draw insights
from huge amounts
of data in no time.
But to empower business
decision makers,
we want to create a report
accessible by the broader team.
This is where Looker
comes into play.
With Looker, we
create a data model
using Looker's
semantic layer, LookML,
that stores the definitions
of our metrics using SQL.
Looker uses this model
to compile and send
SQL queries back to BigQuery on
behalf of non-technical users.
This means we take full
advantage of the power
and intelligence
that BigQuery offers,
all while giving business
users the ability
to explore governed data
without needing an analyst
to write SQL for them.
With our LookML
model in place, we
can build out a dashboard to
influence pricing decisions.
Here, we've built a report that
services historical trends,
building off of that temp
table we created earlier.
And because Looker
compiles SQL on the fly,
we can drill all the way to
SKU level detail from any tile.
Scrolling down on
the report, we've
also created a what-if
tool where decision makers
can see what might
happen if they
change the price of products.
For example, if
you wanted to see
what would happen if the
order volume went down
to 75% of the predicted
value and pricing
across all products
was raised by 25%.
And the best part, this
is all just the beginning.
There are lots more ways
that Google Cloud can
help you optimize
your retail pricing,
like leveraging geospatial
analytics features
to see how the proximity of
competitors impacts sales
or incorporating
publicly available data,
like weather and search
trends into your analysis.
So if you're interested
in learning more
about Google's data
cloud, then make
sure to check out
the links below,
including a step-by-step
tutorial of what
we showed today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]